bring in Shawn O'Hara NFL Network
analyst you can follow the network
analyst on Twitter at Shawn O'Hara 60
and you can see Shawn every Wednesday on
NFL playbook at 6:30 Eastern on the NFL
Network good morning Shawn how are you
good
you being a former center I curious
about the call late in the game with the
Cowboys in their long snapper what did
you see on that I didn't see anything
I saw a center that kind of has his his
normal routine Ladue sea air I think
he's been in the league like 14 years
and look I was a long Stanford
two-hour-long staff in high school a
long snap in college I was a backup long
snapper - Ryan keel pretty much my whole
career in both in Cleveland and with the
Giants and every long snapper has kind
of their pre snap little routine and if
you go back and you look at any snap
from a lot of serie holds the ball with
one hand his right hand and he's waiting
for the kicker to get set and the kicker
gives the nod to the holder and then the
holder looks at the center and then that
and then now he knows he's ready to go
and after holding the ball in his right
hand he now puts he would adjust it and
move his left hand over to it well when
he did that
the defensive lineman jumped so I don't
think he did anything wrong I think the
officials saw the jump and then thought
that he was baited but it was really a
normal movement for him and you know it
was pretty much pretty much a farce from
from a center perspective but I wondered
if this is a case of maybe coach Gruden
saying prior to the game hey you know
what keep an eye on their long snapper
because it looks like he tries to bait
you know the offense or the defensive
lineman yeah every every special teams
coach has a list probably you know
probably grows as the season goes on but
a little little you know part of the IB
SC committee that I think I've mentioned
before in your show but they go up to
the referees and they start you know you
start pleading their case hey keep an
eye on and so on so he does this keep an
eye on this they like to do this so you
know maybe that's something that one of
the coaches alerted them to and said hey
you know this guy is really finicky with
the ball I'll tell you this every
special teams coach on a play like that
when they talk to the players on the
sidelines when they get in the huddle
they are telling the defense watch the
ball don't jump in this situation so
everybody is on point it's a point of
emphasis they're looking at the ball to
see but really I didn't even think he
had I think he was just putting his his
left hand on the ball to position it to
get ready to snap it wasn't like he
flinched her squeezed which I've
actually done on third and long before
you squeeze the handle over squeeze and
Knuckles and you could sometimes get
those defensive linemen to flinch and
jump but I don't even think that was the
case and I also think if that was
something that the referees were
watching they would have come up to him
and say hey look you know their early in
the game they would they would kind of
warn you and say hey be careful with
moving the ball around like that you
know we're gonna flag you for something
they do it a lot with the quarterbacks
when they're in shotgun and you see
moving their hands I've seen the
referees go up to even drew Brees a
couple of nights ago and I said hey when
you when you're calling for the hard
count don't move your hands or I'm gonna
call you for a false start you know this
overshadowed a bigger problem with the
Cowboys in the conservative play calling
of Jason Garrett I mean you have a
timeout you have time and you're only
squeezing off a couple of plays there I
was surprised at that Shawn what it does
he not have confidence in dak Prescott
yeah I thought they wasted I mean I
think they had the ball 52 seconds and
and maybe one or two timeouts and you
know they definitely could have taken a
shot downfield and
you know hey look let's throw throw on
out of the back of the end zone if it's
not there but let's let's at least
stress the defense maybe somebody slips
maybe somebody's falls down so I think
in that position you always want to take
a shot I think we've seen Jason Garrett
get taken a task a couple of times
already this year for being too
conservative not going forward on fourth
down earlier this year so I think that's
just his coaching style I think time
management has not been his forte and I
feel like every year we're talking about
at least two or three games where they
could have used their time better but
even even before all that you know
I just I don't understand why is he
killing it is not more of an emphasis
we can a week out because their defense
is playing pretty good yeah and you know
you their offensive line has actually
struggled this year in pass protection
and any offensive line that is
struggling to protect the quarterback
the way you give them confidence the way
you give them some rhythm is just run
the football and they refuse to do it
hey Shawn O'Hara the NFL Network analyst
former Super Bowl champ with the Giants
the Jags are a mess right now certainly
at quarterback Blake bortles getting
benched
Cody Kessler comes in this is a team
that obviously had Super Bowl
aspirations fighting in the locker room
here can you solve this by bringing in
another quarterback Colin Kaepernick may
be trading for Eli Manning is there a
quick fix here for Jacksonville jag no
there's not and really to be on to the
biggest surprise of all is this defense
because they're healthy
you know the offense they've already
gone through two left tackles cam
Robinson blew his knee out against the
Patriots Josh wells are back of left
tackle who came in and played well he
got hurt things are so bad they sign
Derrick flowers of all people and you
think about the injuries that the
running backs they just traded for
Carlos Hyde on what a Friday so things
they're getting ravaged by injuries on
offense and Blake bortles has always
kind of been the whipping boy
down there for four when things go bad
offensively but this defense I mean I
don't know what in the world's going on
with them but but Shaun if I said you
were the GM and today you're you know
what do we eight days away from the
trade deadline how do you address your
quarterbacking situation in Jacksonville
well I don't I don't know that that's a
quick fix and that's kind of why I'm
saying if you're as a franchise if the
Jacksonville Jaguars are sitting there
saying hey we need to go out and get a
quarterback and that's gonna fix our
issues right now offensively they can't
protect their quarterback so I don't
care who it is back there you know if
you're struggling to protect him and
they're on their third left tackle now
they they've been given up and they have
been able to run the football very well
too so you know the offense is not
clicking that they could certainly use a
spark do you reach out to Eli Manning
would you reach out to the Giant yeah I
mean I'm sure that there have I'm sure
there's lots of conversations that go on
but the tough thing for Jacksonville is
what are you going to give up anyway you
don't want to give up anything right
well you're gonna have to give up
something if you want to if you want to
trade for a quarterback like Eli Manning
or you know somebody that's going to
come in and provide you with some
stability but they're not giving up much
they want to give up much to get Eli
laughing well I don't think Eli is done
yet and I know everybody's kind of
beating him up too but I don't think the
Giants are in any position to trade him
away either right now and you know if
you want to go from the pan into the
fire throw a rookie quarterback behind
the Giants offensive line right now so
it's there's a lot of I know there's a
lot of people that probably look at Jax
will say man they're one quarterback
away from being a better team I don't
look at him like that
when I see what offensively the the way
they got to Dave's to change the game
last year Dan was they ran the heck out
of the ball Leonard fournette was
getting 28 carries a game Blake bortles
was throwing the ball 17 times you know
and then every once in a while it was a
throw to a tight in here and there that
and they played great defense they're
not doing either one of those things so
to me it's not just about the
quarterback what about Colin Kaepernick
I mean I don't know if Colin Kapernick
wants to play football you know I mean
I've heard from a number of people that
he's been offered opportunities to come
in he refuses to sign a one-year deal I
mean I don't know all of the logistics
you know I know that there's got to be
opportunities out there for somebody to
bring him in but you know I'll say this
the last film that I watched on Colin
Kaepernick when he was in San Francisco
Blaine Gabbert was playing better than
him and that's the last memory that I
have of him throwing the football the
inaccurate throws
yes he's athletic and he can run the
football but you know I don't know where
he fits in the into the passing game of
any offense right now I'll leave you
with this the lady on bail situation
when do you think that he shows up in
place for the Steelers I thought he
would have been there by now you know
even if you know look there's a lot of
different ways to handle this I feel
like you know certainly I would have
gone in on the bye week and at least
gotten one paycheck you know even even
if you go in you know a bye week you
take one of those paychecks and then you
know maybe you strain a hamstring was
furiously in practice and then you sit
on the bench I don't know I mean maybe
maybe he doesn't want to do that but the
business side of this has gotten I mean
it's gone on so much longer than I
thought and I think his team they could
really use him I think James Connor has
done a great job filling in for him and
he's a very physical back but lady on
bail is so much more I mean as a
receiver so I'm shocked that he hasn't
played and and at this point now I
almost feel like he's made his mind up
but he's not playing this year but as an
offensive lineman do you have any
problem I know the Steeler offensive
lineman had some things to say about
Le'Veon Bell but this is a guy who knows
his futures not there he's only coming
in for getting paychecks you need him
but do you want him would you have any
problem if you're a member of that
offensive line with the Steelers I don't
think anybody would have a problem once
he walks through that door and look the
locker room is a very forgiving place
and and it's you know you call it a
Brotherhood being on a team or look your
brother anyway
has a brother they've their brother has
done some really dumb stuff and you say
man I can't believe you did that you're
an idiot come over here I'm gonna beat
you up myself and then we're gonna go
have a beer so that's kind of how
brothers handle things I don't think
that they would have any beef when he
rattles off a 70-yard and run for a
touchdown but they would definitely
welcome him back you look around the
league get some some of the guys that
have done Dumber stuff then then sit out
because they didn't like the way their
contract situation played out and
they've been welcomed back into a locker
room good to visit with you is always
Sean hope to have you in studio here at
some point during the season thanks for
joining us that's Sean O'Hara
NFL Network analyst Super Bowl champ
with the Giants and you can see him on
NFL playbook on Wednesdays at 6:30
Eastern on the NFL Network for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]